begin this morning with the intensifying
war in ukraine russia has launched
coordinated artillery and missile
attacks taking aim at a key site in kiev
and other cities in its boldest
offensive yet street fighting broke out
in kiev overnight as russian forces move
closer to capturing the capital as part
of an effort the u.s believes to
overthrow the ukrainian government
ukraine's president velodomir zelinski
said this morning ukrainian forces have
derailed moscow's plans to take keeve
he's refusing to leave ukraine and
insists on fighting the russian assault
president biden spoke to zielinski by
phone on friday offering more american
support to ukraine after the u.s joined
the effort to level economic sanctions
against russian president vladimir putin
directly mr biden instructed the state
department to release 350 million
dollars in military aid to ukraine
holly williams begins our coverage this
morning about 90 miles west of keeve
holly good morning
good morning russian troops may now be
battling for control of ukraine's
capital but they're facing much tougher
resistance than many people expected
ukrainian officials say these videos
show damage they've inflicted on russian
forces ukraine claims its militaries
killed more than a thousand russian
troops which we cannot verify
the ukrainians are digging deep to
defend their country in kiev the
government says it's handed out eighteen
thousand guns to volunteers and arriving
into the city yesterday we found
checkpoints manned by reservists
ukraine's president vladimir zelinski
shared this video early this morning to
reassure his people he's still in the
country he reportedly turned down a u.s
offer to help him evacuate and told
european leaders on a video call
thursday they may never see him alive
again
vladimir putin claims he launched this
bloody war to prevent genocide in
ukraine but there is no evidence of
genocide instead he's drawn
international condemnation and revulsion
now we see him
for what he is
a blood-stained aggressor who believes
in imperial conquest
and the invasion has also sparked mass
protests across russia
where demonstrations like this one in
saint petersburg are illegal
nearly 2 000 have reportedly been
detained i think that most of russians
don't support this
it's horrible i'm sorry so shocked
i just can't help crying
russia claims it isn't targeting
civilians but ukraine says its attacks
are indiscriminate today this apartment
building was hit in kiev
this morning while filming in a hospital
the fighting came close to us we're
hearing a lot of gunfire obviously
fighting taking place we think about
three blocks from here
they've cancelled all elective surgeries
and sent many non-critical patients home
to reinvent themselves as a combat
hospital doctor elizabeth
told us they haven't slept for three
days
why are you staying you could leave it's
my home
i'm at my own country i was born here
and i would live here for all my time
all my life
even if that means dying here
if it's mean fighting for my home
in that video this morning president
zielenski said our weapon is the truth
and the truth is that we'll defend our
country our land and our children
michelle
holly williams thank you